Trump an insurrectionist sir well I
think certain there self-evident you saw
it all now whether the 14 commandment
applies and let the court make that
decision but he certainly supported an
Insurrection and no question about it
none zero and uh he seems to be doubling
down on about everything destroying
democracy is totally fine if Democrats
do it Joe Biden giving his Blessing to
the bombshell ruling that kicked Donald
Trump off the ballot in Colorado you can
blame these four Democrat picked
Colorado Supreme Court Justices for the
landmark decision they pushed a novel
legal theory that sounds like it was
written by msnbc's prime time deciding
that the former president's actions on
January 6th make him ineligible to even
run for president again and are using
the 14th Amendment A Relic from the
Civil War era to stop insurrectionists
from holding office I think we need a
little fact check on that last one Trump
has not been charged with insurrection
the Trump campaign vowing to quickly
appeal at the Supreme Court and the
former president himself railing against
it listen they want to silence me
because I will never let them silence
you and in the end they're not after me
they're after you I just happen to be
standing in their way the liberals who
Crow endlessly about threats to
democracy seem to be pretty happy about
taking it away from voters in Colorado
this is not a crazy thing for a
democracy to do it's very much like the
re ing of the conservative legal
Community the conservatives on the
Supreme Court who usually go on and on
and on about states rights are
hypocrites he was an enemy of the
Constitution simply a plain reading of
the US Constitution this is not partisan
this is about applying historic
principles what do you say to the um to
the Republican candidates argument that
this should be the voters should have
the say and not the courts why are you
standing with
Confederates who betrayed this country
Colorado's anti-democratic ruling could
open the floodgates and destabilize our
elections a dozen other states have
pending lawsuits which could bar Trump
from the ballot and now liberal
California is looking into blocking
people from voting for Trump okay you
went to law
school you did right I did okay good
when you saw this drop last night what
was the first thing that went through
your mind Harold I wanted to read the
decision uh second thing that popped in
my mind was first good to be back second
thing to be back second thing that
popped in my mind was um we're going to
get the court the Supreme Court's going
to waigh on this and we'll have an
opportunity to retire this issue one way
or the other uh as you stated there are
a number of states that have been
flirting with this three I hadn't heard
President Biden because he hadn't spoken
yet uh we all have opinions about what
happened on January 6th uh the thing
that I was most concerned about is it
related to President Trump uh and still
I'm still bothered by I was there he had
every right to believe that he won he
had every right to tell people that he
won every every right to tell people you
should go tell them that I won but when
he saw the thing kind of got out of
control for three hours and didn't call
uh his own vice president was there
that's still what bothers me I'm not
sure that's in that's him being a part
of an Insurrection but it's certainly uh
he's going to have to answer for that
but I'd rather have him answer to that
answer to that to the voters Jesse and
so I'm concerned and bothered by the
decision but I'm relieved by the fact
that Emily and I have a legal background
I believe that the Supreme Court is
likely to take this up because you have
you have different states with different
positions on this you have some states
have said it's okay now you have a state
that's saying he should not be on the
ballot uh based on what I know if I were
on the Supreme Court US Supreme Court I
would overrule them okay Emily so
they're going to take this up we believe
in January when would they decide this
case well usually decisions come out in
June this would likely have an expedited
decision however and that was part of
the reason why this decision was stayed
and why scota said yes we'll take it um
I have to say I obviously agree with
Harold but I want to point out where the
analogy falters which is you know he's
grateful for the Supreme Court but it's
sort of like you know getting your leg
chopped off and being like thank
goodness I'm right next to a hospital to
fix it the whole point is you shouldn't
have your leg chopped off in the first
place and when you talk about multiple
States flirting with it most of them
dismissed it outright for the fact that
it is faulty so to me my first thought
when I heard about this was here's just
yet another way that they are trying to
take him down and most importantly
another way that they meaning the
liberal leftist woke Democrats are
trying to take away power from the
people and for everyone saying that are
Advocates of this well multiple sources
say yes it pertains to the office of the
presidency and well it couldn't possibly
preclude this or most totally
irrelevantly unlike whoever just blanked
on her name said it on there um well
what if a Confederate had had decided to
be president or had won the election at
the end of the day the gross majority of
democratic presidents of democracy Canon
states that indeed this office is
excluded and decision after decision
held that the office of the presidency
was excluded from section three and only
recently in the grand Camp of things had
decision started coming out saying
something different and so when I look
at that volume and I Look to people who
are way more educated and smarter than I
am they overwhelmingly say at the end of
the day all you are doing is having
partisan state election boards and an
activist judges take away the power from
the people let the people decide all
this is going to do is make everyone mad
and remind everyone why activist judges
hold no place in our democracy and for
some reason they are continuing to
flourish under this Administration Dana
so last election we had uh interference
by the CIA by the FBI by big Tech and
now it looks like you're going to have
judges and lawyers again interfering in
this election well I I actually think
this is going to be taken care of pretty
quickly I think that it'll be um
expedited so quickly that you might have
a decision even before the end of this
year or the first week of January
because of the way that the ballots work
and also because I think it's pretty
clear and if you look at the
preponderance of the response today it's
probably the most agreement you've had
on the left and the right that this is
actually a dog of a case and it's not
going to go forward most Supreme Court
cases are decided 90 81 they're hardly
the ones that we all talk about are the
ones that were like the most difficult
ones for them to answer I actually don't
think this is going to be that difficult
to answer Minnesota not the most
conservative State they they Supreme
Court was like yeah we're not touching
this with a 10- foot pole walking away
from it so I think that the Supreme
Court knows we need to be decisive and
we need to be quick about this and we
need to see but uh what we can do the
other thing is President Biden when he
when he was asked he said he was asked
was Trump an insurrectionist and he says
well I think that's self-evident sir
that's not how it works in the country
like I could say
it's self-evident to me that Hunter
Biden was accepting bribes on behalf of
his father who was given him a wink and
a notd I mean self-evident to me that is
actually not how it's supposed to work
there that's why we have an impeachment
that's why Hunters under indictment and
he will get his day in court also all
the liberals who are totally freaking
out about this uh and with Glee thinking
yeah now we've really got him just wait
until the Supreme Court pushes it back
and says no then all of them are going
to say that the US Supreme Court is
illegitimate and that they've been
totally bought off by everybody else it
will be Preposterous on the politics
just two points president Trump's Ascent
in the 2024 primary actually started
last April when Alvin Bragg here in New
York brought that CA the tax case
against him and that's when you started
to see it go up now it's been
supercharged with every other legal case
that's come forward and this one perhaps
it puts him over the top uh Democrats
are providing him all of his best
moments yes and so if I were Biden what
I would have said is I'll let the courts
decide about insurrectionist and about
this but I'll tell you this if Trump's
on the ballot I'm gonna beat him right
on the merits and then walk away instead
he well I'm I guess I'm not surprised
about how he handled it and that's all I
have to say doesn't Jack Smith he has a
case up with the court about whether the
president can be charged criminally for
executing his duties they might knock
that out too right Greg I love the med
Glee over this it's hysterical because
it just betrays their stupidity I mean
if you think this is valid or a win it's
so un unconstitutional this is like
cheering because you got a girl's phone
number and it turns out to be for the
suicide hotline that's how bad this is I
feel so bad I was watching earli I feel
so bad for Mary Trump she has no idea
this is going to blow up in her face not
like anyone will notice but still
remember remember this is a system based
on President Harry Reid changed the
filibuster Rule and what happened
Republicans filibustered meric Garland
allowing Trump to get the Supreme Court
majority which
ironically will solve this mess so this
could also blow up in the dem's faces
much like a puffer fish with diarrhea
also known as the Mary Trump all right
the Dems aren't learning the more they
push Trump away the closer he gets he
really is like booze to the Dems who are
all all full-blown Trump aholics right
and what do Al Trump aholics Do they
hide bottles all over the house hoping
no one will see it but the obsession
only grows they put Trump here let's put
him over there but then he just pops out
and it's just you just need it more than
ever it it makes him just more exciting
he doesn't have to say or do anything in
fact that would be my advice to him let
them let these crazy people elect you
the more unhinged Ed and old the Dem
sound about Trump the more punk rock the
more rap the more metal Trump becomes
he's like a mix of the Sex Pistols
Public Enemy and Metallica all rolled
into one he's America's bad boy and he
should just let them do all the work and
sit back and regain the White House all
right the one good thing if the court
does say 90 for I think because I think
there's a chance it will is that it it
will help deflate something that bothers
me it will deflate this partisan
argument about Judges being Democrat or
very deminted Jud repblic judge in cour
deci that this is not this is
notal did you hear the Supreme Court
ruling on cannibalism
81 I just made that up so you did not
just I did when she
saidar keeping that in your back swear
everyone I'm Brian killme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now